هل تتراجع مشاهدك هذه في الايام القادمه
288 ساعه قضتها هذه الفتاه تحت الانقاض
بكهرمان مارش مناقضه هي وحالات كثيره
سابقه لتاكيدات مختصين بشان امكانيه
البقاء على قيد الحياه تحت الانقاض طوال
الايام الماضيه تغلبت الحياه على الموت
على هذا النحو المؤثر في تركيا لكن بعد 11
يوما يعلن انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ
في نصف الولايات المنكوبه وفق ما اكدته
مصادر في اداره الكوارث بينما تظل عمليات
البحث والانقاذ الجاريه في غاز عنتاب
وديار بكر واديامان وهاتاي
انتهاء عمليات الانقاذ يغير طريقه تعامل
السلطات مع الانقاض الهائله ويسرع عمليات
رفعها ما يعني البدء في عمليات اعاده
الاعمار بشكل اسرع وصولا لحل ازمه
المشردين لكن رفع الانقاض دون اعتبار لهدف
الانقاذ يقضي تقريبا الاحتمالات العثور
على احياء في المناطق المعنيه ليست يسيره
مهمه اعاده الاعمار التي تنتظر السلطات في
سائر الولايات التركيه المنكوبه بالنظر
لحجم الدمار الذي اتى وفق شهادات على
قرابه نصف مدينه انطاكيا قلبي ولايه هاتاي
اكثر الولايات تضررا وهي ليست وحدها في
ذلك فهناك مدن شديده التضرر كغاز عنتاب
وكرمان مرعش على ان مهام رفع الانقاض
القائمه الان لن تقتصر على ما اسقطه
الزلزال من مبان فبحسب السلطات التركيه
هناك حاجه عاجله لهدم اكثر من 50 الف مبنى
في الولايات المتضرره ما يعني ايضا
امتدادا لمهام رفع الانقاض التي ينتظر ان
تبدا من بعدها ما ترجوه الدوله من اعاده
الاعمار